- Знову вітаємо у курсі «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень».
Мене звати John Watrous, я — технічний директор з освіти в IBM Quantum.
Це сьомий урок серії, і в цьому уроці ми розглянемо задачу оцінки фази та те, як її можна розв'язати за допомогою квантового комп'ютера.
Потім ми застосуємо оцінку фази до задачі факторизації цілих чисел, яку ми обговорювали на попередньому уроці.
Ми отримаємо алгоритм Шора, який дозволяє факторизувати цілі числа з поліноміальними витратами, або за поліноміальний час, якщо ти хочеш
думати в термінах часу, необхідного для виконання, а не кількості елементарних операцій.
Це — певною мірою — перлина квантових алгоритмів, і хоча факторизація великих цілих чисел
може мати обмежену практичну цінність для більшості людей, вона залишається одним із найпереконливіших свідчень на користь гіпотези про те, що квантові комп'ютери матимуть
вражаючі переваги над класичними. Ось огляд уроку.
Ми почнемо з визначення самої задачі оцінки фази, а потім обговоримо метод її розв'язання за допомогою квантового комп'ютера.
Ми будемо рухатись поступово, починаючи з того, що можна вважати своєрідним розминанням.
У задачі оцінки фази мета полягає в апроксимації певного дійсного числа, і в цій частині-розминці ми побачимо, як можна отримати
апроксимацію цього числа з дуже низькою точністю.
Цього буде недостатньо для факторизації, коли ми застосовуємо наш розв'язок задачі оцінки фази до факторизації цілих чисел,
нам насправді знадобиться апроксимація з досить високою точністю, але тим не менш корисно починати з такого розминання,
щоб зрозуміти, як усе це працює загалом.
Потім ми розглянемо питання про те, як можна отримати більшу точність, і це дуже природно приведе нас до операції, відомої як квантове перетворення Фур'є.
Ми побачимо, що це за операція і як її можна реалізувати за допомогою квантового circuit.
А маючи її, ми зможемо застосувати її до оцінки фази, щоб отримати загальну процедуру розв'язання задачі з дуже високою точністю.
Потім, в останній частині уроку, ми побачимо, як розв'язання задачі оцінки фази дозволяє нам ефективно факторизувати цілі числа.
І конкретно ми отримаємо алгоритм Шора для факторизації цілих чисел, або принаймні щось еквівалентне алгоритму Шора.
Цей підхід працює так: ми фактично даємо собі проміжний крок — ще одну задачу, яка називається задачею пошуку порядку.
Зокрема, ми побачимо, як розв'язати задачу пошуку порядку за допомогою процедури оцінки фази, а потім побачимо, як факторизувати цілі числа,
розв'язуючи задачу пошуку порядку. Ми почнемо зі спеціального випадку теореми, яка називається спектральною теоремою,
і зокрема зосередимось на тому, що ця теорема говорить нам про унітарні матриці.
Спектральна теорема — це дуже важлива теорема з лінійної алгебри та функціонального аналізу.
Вона розповідає нам щось цікаве про те, як певні лінійні відображення можна виразити у певній формі, яку часто називають спектральним розкладом,
корисним з багатьох причин.
І, як я вже сказав, ми зосередимось на тому, що ця теорема говорить нам про унітарні матриці.
Спектральна теорема є більш загальною. Вона не працює для всіх матриць, але вона працює для класу матриць,
які називаються нормальними матрицями, що включають усі унітарні матриці, а також деякі матриці, які не є унітарними.
Але для простоти ми обмежимо нашу увагу лише унітарними матрицями, оскільки це все, що нам потрібно для цього уроку.
Ось формулювання спектральної теореми лише для унітарних матриць.
Припустимо, що U — це унітарна матриця розміру N на N.
Теорема стверджує, що має існувати ортонормований базис з векторів — psi один через psi N,
разом із N комплексними числами Lambda один через Lambda N, які всі лежать на комплексному одиничному колі, так що U можна виразити, як показано в цьому рівнянні.
Це називається спектральним розкладом U, як я вже згадував, і буває дуже зручно знати, що U можна записати у такому вигляді.
Іноді корисно мати ці вектори і ці числа, коли ми працюємо з конкретною унітарною матрицею U, і також може бути дуже
корисно просто знати, що такий вираз завжди можливий — як спосіб доведення певних тверджень про унітарні матриці, наприклад.
У цьому формулюванні теореми кожне з цих чисел, Lambda один через lambda N, записано особливим чином
як E у ступені два pi I помножене на theta, де кожна з тет — theta один через theta N — є дійсним числом, і ми повернемось до цього способу
запису кожного з цих чисел трохи згодом.
Важлива особливість цих векторів і чисел полягає в тому, що кожен вектор psi K має бути власним вектором матриці U з відповідним власним значенням lambda K.
Це означає, що якщо ми помножимо psi K на U, ми отримаємо lambda K помножене на psi K.
Тобто те, що U робить із кожним із цих векторів, — просто множить його на відповідне число lambda K.
Загалом, для довільного вектора U не буде діяти таким чином, але власні вектори — особливі.
І теорема говорить нам, що насправді існує ортонормований базис із цих власних векторів.
До речі, це рівняння тут випливає з виразу, який ми маємо для U з теореми, разом із тим фактом, що вектори є ортонормованими.
WEBVTT
Якщо ти помножиш вираз U на будь-який psi K і скористаєшся ортонормованістю векторів, ти отримаєш суму, в якій всі доданки дорівнюють нулю,
крім одного, і цей єдиний залишений доданок виглядає ось так.
Тепер ми можемо визначити задачу оцінки фази.
Задача є трохи незвичайною, як ми побачимо.
Нам дано дві речі. По-перше, нам дано опис унітарного квантового circuit,
що діє на N qubits для деякого вибору N, і коли ми говоримо, що цей circuit є унітарним,
ми просто маємо на увазі, що всі gate є унітарними, тобто в цьому circuit немає вимірювань.
По-друге, нам дано N-qubit стан psi, і це незвичайна частина.
У нас насправді є квантовий стан як вхідні дані для цієї задачі, і це єдина копія цього стану.
Для всіх інших обчислювальних задач, які ми обговорювали в цій серії, вхідні дані були класичними — або у вигляді рядка бітів, або у вигляді чорного ящика.
І це не дивно, адже обчислювальні задачі, з якими ми стикаємось у повсякденному житті, зазвичай є класичними,
бо це задачі, які нас найбільше цікавлять.
Цю задачу можна уявляти як таку, що з'являється або, скоріш за все, з'явиться як підзадача.
І процедура оцінки фази, яку ми зрештою отримаємо, — це те, що ми зазвичай використовуємо як підпрограму
всередині якогось більшого обчислення, мабуть, для класичної задачі, яка нас цікавить.
Тепер це буде задачею-обіцянкою, і стан psi — це не просто якийсь квантовий стан.
Нам обіцяють, що psi є власним вектором тієї унітарної операції U, яку описує даний circuit.
І мета полягає в тому, щоб знайти або наблизити власне значення, яке відповідає власному вектору psi.
Сформулюємо задачу трохи більш точно.
Вхідні дані складаються з унітарного квантового circuit на N qubits, який можна закодувати як рядок бітів
будь-яким методом, який ми обираємо для кодування описів квантових circuits, разом із N-qubit станом psi.
Ми можемо назвати circuit як завгодно, але те, що насправді важливо з точки зору формулювання цієї задачі, — це сама унітарна операція
яка виконується під час запуску circuit, і ця унітарна операція описується матрицею U.
Але нам дається не U як матриця, а лише опис квантового circuit, який реалізує U.
Обіцянка, як я вже зазначив, полягає в тому, що psi є власним вектором U.
Тож якби ми запустили наш circuit на psi, ми б отримали psi помножений на власне значення,
що у цій ситуації було б глобальною фазою.
І нарешті, результатом задачі є апроксимація власного значення, що відповідає psi, і зокрема ми шукаємо
апроксимацію дійсного числа theta від нуля до одиниці, включно з нулем, але не включно з одиницею,
яке задовольняє рівняння, показане на екрані.
Щоб пояснити цей спосіб параметризації власного значення, що відповідає psi, а також уточнити, що ми маємо на увазі під апроксимацією,
намалюємо комплексне одиничне коло.
Ми можемо розмістити числа один, I, мінус один та мінус I на їхніх звичних місцях і розглянути
довільну точку на колі, параметризовану через theta, як у формулюванні задачі.
Це точка, яку ми отримуємо, якщо починаємо з одиниці та обертаємося на кут два pi помножене на theta, тобто кут — це не theta, а два pi theta,
і ще один спосіб думати про це: якщо ми починаємо з одиниці та проходимо відстань два pi theta по самому колу,
ми потрапляємо до нашої точки E у ступені два pi theta.
Кожна точка комплексного одиничного кола може бути представлена таким чином для єдиного вибору theta.
Це тому, що ми робимо повне коло, коли theta змінюється від нуля до одиниці, і якби ми дійшли до theta рівне одиниці,
ми б повернулись туди, де починали при theta рівне нулю, саме тому ми включаємо нуль, але не включаємо одиницю.
Щоб переконатись, що кожна точка комплексного одиничного кола відповідає єдиному значенню theta у розглянутому діапазоні.
Є різні способи апроксимувати конкретне значення theta, але ми апроксимуватимемо theta дробом,
де знаменник — це два у степені M для деякого додатного цілого числа M, а чисельник — ціле число y
від нуля до два у степені M мінус один.
Можеш думати про це як про апроксимацію theta з m бітами, і ми могли б записати це число в двійковому нотації,
де у нас є двійкова точка, за якою йде двійкове представлення Y.
Я кажу «двійкова точка», а не «десяткова», бо «десятковий» означає основу 10, а я говорю про основу два,
але ідея та сама. Але в будь-якому разі ми можемо просто думати про це як про дріб, як показано на екрані.
І для ясності, коли ми думаємо про апроксимації в цьому контексті, слід розуміти, що значення theta
WEBVTT
поблизу нуля та значення theta поблизу одиниці насправді близькі одне до одного.
Наприклад, якщо theta дорівнює 0.99 і ми апроксимуємо це значення theta значенням нуль,
то це досить добра апроксимація в тому сенсі, що вона відрізняється від реального значення лише на одну соту, якщо ми обходимо коло
і повертаємось до нуля, коли досягаємо одиниці.
Термін «за модулем один» іноді використовується для опису ситуації, коли ми по суті прирівнюємо theta рівне одиниці до theta рівне нулю.
Суть у тому, що нас насправді цікавить розташування точки E у ступені два pi I theta на одиничному колі,
і такий спосіб апроксимації theta має сенс, коли ми маємо цю мету на увазі.
Саме формулювання задачі, як воно показано на екрані, не уточнює, наскільки хорошою має бути апроксимація theta,
але це можна налаштовувати залежно від наших потреб.
У деяких ситуаціях нас може задовольнити апроксимація theta з низькою точністю, а в інших ситуаціях нам може знадобитись
апроксимація з дуже високою точністю, і формулювання задачі може бути уточнено відповідно.
Далі ми побачимо, як можна розв'язати задачу оцінки фази за допомогою квантового комп'ютера, і почнемо з розминання.
Це не буде нашим остаточним розв'язком задачі.
Що ми зробимо — скористаємось явищем фазового відкату, щоб спробувати дізнатися щось про власне значення, що відповідає даному власному вектору.
Нагадаємо, що в задачі оцінки фази нам дається опис унітарного квантового circuit для деякої операції U,
і перше, що ми робимо, — це використовуємо цей опис circuit, щоб створити новий circuit, який реалізує контрольовану операцію U, як показано на екрані.
Це досить просто зробити. Ми можемо додати керувальний qubit, який показано зверху на цій діаграмі,
і використовувати цей новий керувальний qubit як керування для кожного gate, що міститься в нашому circuit.
Тобто всі gate застосовуються, якщо цей керувальний qubit встановлено в один, і жоден з них не застосовується, якщо керувальний qubit встановлено в нуль,
а це означає, що нам знадобиться контрольована версія кожного gate, що міститься в circuit U, але нам не обов'язково думати про ці нові контрольовані gate
як про окремі gate, якщо ми не хочемо. Їх можна реалізувати як невеликі circuits, складені з gate будь-якого набору gate,
який ми обрали. І маючи контрольовану версію U, ми можемо розглянути запуск цього circuit,
де ми спочатку переводимо керувальний qubit у суперпозицію нуля і одиниці, застосовуємо контрольований gate U до власного вектора psi, який нам дано,
а потім застосовуємо Hadamard gate до керування і вимірюємо.
Ми побачимо, чому має сенс робити саме це, коли будемо проводити аналіз, але навіть до деталей ми одразу можемо помітити схожість
з алгоритмом Дойча, наприклад, де ми застосовуємо кілька Hadamard gate і вимірюємо як спосіб ефективно досліджувати,
що робить якась задана операція.
Тут це контрольоване унітарне перетворення, а не gate запиту, але задіяні дуже схожі ідеї.
Тож розглянемо, що робить circuit.
Початковий стан — це власний вектор psi, взятий у тензорний добуток з нульовим станом для керувального qubit,
застосування першого Hadamard gate перетворює стан верхнього qubit на стан плюс, і ми можемо розписати весь стан, як показано тут.
Потім ми застосовуємо контрольовану операцію U, і це означає, що U застосовується до psi, коли керувальний qubit дорівнює одиниці,
але не тоді, коли він дорівнює нулю. Тому ми отримуємо стан pi два, записаний на екрані.
Ми можемо спростити стан, використовуючи той факт, що psi є власним вектором U з власним значенням e у ступені два pi I theta.
Тому ми отримуємо це власне значення, що множить другий доданок, але не перший.
І ми можемо спростити, скориставшись білінійністю тензорного добутку.
Тут ми маємо явище фазового відкату, але цього разу воно відбувається для довільного власного вектора psi довільної унітарної операції U,
а не для операції NOT, що застосовується до стану мінус, як у більш конкретному випадку.
Отже, це стан після застосування контрольованої операції U.
До речі, варто зупинитись і помітити, що стан нижніх N qubits залишається власним вектором psi.
Це чудово, бо це дає нам можливість знову використати його, якщо ми вирішимо так зробити.
Потім виконується другий Hadamard gate, і ось який стан ми отримуємо.
Я не показав тут усіх деталей виведення, але якщо ти застосуєш Hadamard gate і спростиш, ти маєш отримати саме це.
Тобто це стан безпосередньо перед вимірюванням.
Тому ми можемо зосередитись на цьому стані, щоб побачити, що ми можемо дізнатися про theta шляхом вимірювання.
І якщо ми вимірюємо верхній qubit або крайній правий qubit, ось імовірності, які ми отримуємо для двох результатів.
Тут я використав кілька базових формул, які пов'язують синуси і косинуси з комплексними експонентами, щоб виразити ці імовірності
через синуси і косинуси.
Зокрема, імовірність отримати нуль — це косинус у квадраті від pi помножене на theta, а імовірність отримати один
WEBVTT
— це синус у квадраті від того самого кута. І це має сенс, адже синус у квадраті плюс косинус у квадраті від будь-якого кута рівні одиниці.
Тому наші імовірності в сумі дають одиницю, як і очікується.
А ось графік цих імовірностей як функції theta.
Для ясності, це графік самих імовірностей, а не графік, що зображує єдиний розподіл імовірностей, наприклад.
Наприклад, якщо theta дорівнює одній другій, то імовірність отримати результат один, показаний фіолетовим, рівна одиниці,
а імовірність отримати результат нуль, показаний синім, рівна нулю.
З іншого боку, якщо theta дорівнює одній четвертій або трьом четвертим, то обидва результати рівноймовірні.
І звичайно, для всіх значень theta сума імовірностей рівна одиниці, як ми вже зазначали.
Тому ми не дізнаємось точно, чому дорівнює theta, з цієї процедури, але вона дає нам певну інформацію про theta.
І якщо уявити ситуацію, коли нам обіцяно, що theta дорівнює нулю або theta дорівнює одній другій, ця процедура скаже нам,
яка саме з двох можливостей має місце.
Ось простий спосіб використання явища фазового відкату, щоб дізнатися дещо про власне значення.
Тож як можна дізнатись більше про власне значення?
Тут ситуація така, що ми можемо дозволити незнанню бути нашим провідником.
Адже є не так багато речей, які ми можемо зробити.
Ми майже нічого не знаємо про власний вектор, і ми також мало знаємо про операцію U.
У нас є circuit для U, але, можливо, це жахлива заплутана мішанина, в якій ми не зможемо розібратись, розглядаючи її.
Але один природний варіант — запустити circuit кілька разів.
Зокрема, ми могли б спробувати зробити те саме, що ми щойно робили, тільки замість одної контрольованої операції U
застосувати цю операцію двічі. Або ми могли б застосовувати її будь-яку кількість разів, але почнемо з двох, щоб подивитись, що вийде.
Що ж, те, що відбувається, насправді досить просте. Застосовуючи контрольовану операцію U двічі, ми фактично просто
зводимо власне значення у квадрат, оскільки воно буде відкатуватись у фазу верхнього qubit двічі, а не один раз.
І тому, коли ми думаємо про імовірності результатів як функцію theta, ми по суті просто подвоюємо частоту.
Для кожного можливого вибору theta імовірності результатів такі самі, як якби ми подвоїли theta і взяли дробову частину,
щоб отримати число від нуля до одиниці.
Наприклад, якщо theta дорівнює одній другій, то власне значення рівне мінус одиниці.
Тому, застосовуючи U двічі, ми фактично зводимо власне значення у квадрат, і результат такий самий, як і для theta рівного нулю.
А саме: імовірність результату нуль, показаного синім, дорівнює одиниці, а імовірність результату один, показаного фіолетовим, дорівнює нулю.
Це дуже просто, але таким чином ми справді можемо отримати деяку додаткову інформацію про theta.
Наприклад, якщо ми заздалегідь знаємо, що theta дорівнює нулю або theta дорівнює одній четвертій, то цей circuit покаже нам,
яка з двох можливостей є правильною.
З іншого боку, ми більше не можемо відрізнити випадок theta рівного нулю від випадку theta рівного одній другій.
Тому ця процедура не є строго кращою за попередню, де ми мали один контрольований gate U, але, також запускаючи цей circuit,
ми можемо отримати додаткову інформацію.
Не одразу зрозуміло, як додаткову інформацію, яку ми можемо отримати, ітеруючи контрольовану операцію U кілька разів,
можна поєднати з інформацією, яку ми отримуємо, виконуючи її лише один раз, і насправді є кілька способів продовжити.
Наприклад, існує техніка, яка називається ітеративною оцінкою фази, яка передбачає запуск circuits, подібних до тих, що ми вже бачили,
разом з деякими незначними варіаціями, щоб отримати апроксимацію theta.
Але я опишу те, що можна назвати більш традиційним підходом, де ми використовуємо єдиний квантовий circuit із кількома керувальними qubits,
які контролюють різну кількість ітерацій унітарної операції U.
Спочатку я опишу, як це працює для двох керувальних qubits, а потім трохи пізніше узагальнимо це на більш ніж два керувальні qubits.
Ось квантовий circuit, що використовує два керувальні qubits.
Верхній керувальний qubit контролює одну операцію U, тоді як другий зверху qubit контролює дві копії U.
Тобто ми поєднуємо два circuit, які ми бачили раніше, таким чином, що використовується єдина копія
власного вектора psi, яку ми маємо.
Зверни увагу, однак, що Hadamard gate після контрольованих операцій U прибрані, і вимірювань поки що немає.
Що ми збираємось зробити — подивитись, як працює цей circuit, а потім зрозуміємо, що ми повинні зробити з верхніми двома qubits,
щоб дізнатись якомога більше про значення theta, яке ми намагаємось апроксимувати.
Після виконання Hadamard gate ми отримуємо стан, показаний на екрані.
WEBVTT
І це буде зручним способом запису стану, щоб побачити, що відбудеться далі.
A нуль та A один — це біти, і якщо ми думаємо про два верхніх qubits як про двохqubit регістр,
ми вважаємо A нуль, що відповідає верхньому qubit, молодшим значущим бітом, а A один, що відповідає нижньому керувальному qubit,
старшим значущим бітом.
Після виконання першої контрольованої операції U ми отримуємо цей стан.
Класичний стан верхнього керувального qubit — це A нуль, тому результат фазового відкату
можна виразити таким чином. Потім після виконання другої та третьої контрольованих операцій U
ми отримуємо цей стан.
Ідея та сама, що і для першої, тільки цього разу ми застосовуємо контрольовану операцію U двічі.
Тому ми множимо A один на два в показнику, щоб це відобразити.
І тепер ми можемо спростити цей вираз, думаючи про біти A один та A нуль разом як про ціле число від нуля до трьох у двійковому записі.
Тобто, коли ми думаємо про двобітний рядок A один A нуль як про двійкове кодування цілого числа,
ми отримуємо два помножене на A один плюс A нуль.
І мається на увазі, що коли ми пишемо «кет X», ми говоримо про X, записаний у вигляді двійкового рядка довжиною
два у двійковому записі. Тож зосередимось тепер на цих двох керувальних qubits, щоб зрозуміти, що ми можемо дізнатись про theta з них у цей момент.
Решта N qubits все ще перебувають у тому самому стані psi, який нам було спочатку надано, що справді є чудовою особливістю цього підходу:
як я вже говорив, ми можемо знову використати цей стан, якщо хочемо отримати ще більше інформації про theta.
Але поки що давайте просто подумаємо, що ми можемо дізнатись із цих двох керувальних qubits.
Щоб зрозуміти, як діяти далі, уявімо, що нам обіцяно, що theta дорівнює Y поділене на чотири
для деякого цілого числа y від нуля до трьох.
Загалом, theta може не бути одним із цих чотирьох значень, але це природний випадок для розгляду.
Ми бачили в оригінальній версії процедури з одним керувальним qubit, що якби нам було обіцяно, що theta — або нуль, або одна друга,
circuit показав би, яке з двох значень воно є. Ми також помітили, що у версії, де ми застосовували контрольовану операцію U двічі,
ми могли бездоганно розрізнити випадок theta рівного нулю від випадку theta рівного одній четвертій.
Тому ми можемо сподіватись, що за допомогою нашого нового circuit ми зможемо розрізнити ці чотири випадки.
По суті, ми використовуємо поняття задачі-обіцянки, щоб спростити задачу, щоб зрозуміти, як діяти далі.
І це непогана ідея загалом. Якщо у тебе є задача і ти не знаєш, як її розв'язати, спробуй спростити її.
Якщо ти можеш розв'язати простішу задачу, отримані знання можуть допомогти у розв'язанні більш загальної задачі.
А якщо ти не можеш розв'язати простішу задачу, то, мабуть, ти ще не готовий до більш загальної.
Тому продовжуй спрощувати, поки не зможеш її розв'язати.
Так, повертаючись до нашої задачі, визначимо двохqubit стан для кожного з можливих значень Y.
Іншими словами, phi Y дорівнює стану, показаному у верхній частині екрана, коли theta вибирається конкретно як Y поділене на чотири.
А ось ці чотири стани, записані явно.
Щоб повторити: якщо theta дорівнює Y поділеному на чотири, де Y — нуль, один, два або три, і ми запускаємо наш circuit,
ми отримуємо один із цих чотирьох станів — той, що відповідає правильному значенню Y.
І ми просто хочемо дізнатись, який саме.
І питання: чи це можливо?
І відповідь на це питання — так, тому що ці чотири стани ортогональні.
Якщо обчислиш скалярний добуток будь-якої пари з них, ти отримаєш нуль.
А оскільки вони ортогональні, їх можна бездоганно розрізнити проективним вимірюванням.
І зокрема, ми можемо виразити таке вимірювання, визначивши одну проекцію для кожного вектора, як тут.
Це завжди спрацьовує, коли є ортонормований базис, і ти можеш звірити це з визначеннями, які ми бачили в уроці три,
для цього конкретного випадку, якщо хочеш. Тому ми робимо висновок, що нашу задачу
можна розв'язати, тобто дізнатись значення Y зі стану, показаного у верхній частині екрана.
І якщо ми хочемо зробити це за допомогою квантового circuit, ми можемо діяти так, як я зараз поясню.
Спочатку ми можемо визначити унітарну матрицю V, стовпці якої — чотири вектори, перелічені по порядку.
Ця матриця матиме дію, описану у нижній частині екрана, на стандартних базисних станах,
і ми можемо записати матрицю, щоб подивитись, як вона виглядає.
Оскільки V відображає кожен стандартний базисний стан каппа Y на вектор phi Y, застосовуючи V спряжену,
або іншими словами, обернену матрицю V до phi Y, ми перетворимо його назад до відповідного стандартного базисного стану.
WEBVTT
Тому ми можемо застосувати V спряжену до будь-якого стану, отриманого в нашому circuit.
А потім, якщо виконати вимірювання у стандартному базисі, ми отримаємо число Y, яке шукаємо, виражене у вигляді рядка довжиною два у двійковому записі.
Перш ніж іти далі, поговоримо трохи більше про унітарну матрицю V.
Це особлива матриця, і, можливо, ти вже бачив її раніше.
Це матриця, пов'язана з лінійною операцією на чотиривимірних векторах, відомою як дискретне перетворення Фур'є.
Більш точно: дискретне перетворення Фур'є можна визначити для будь-якого додатного цілого виміру, і ми розглянемо його в загальному вигляді через кілька хвилин.
І ось як воно виглядає конкретно, коли вимір дорівнює чотирьом.
Ми можемо думати про дискретне перетворення Фур'є по-різному.
Можна думати про нього суто абстрактно як про лінійне відображення на векторах, яке можна представити матрицею.
А також можна думати про нього як про обчислювальну задачу, де нам дано вектор і ми хочемо обчислити результат
застосування цього лінійного відображення.
Це виявляється неймовірно важливою обчислювальною задачею, і існує надзвичайно ефективний алгоритм для її виконання,
відомий як швидке перетворення Фур'є.
Насправді, це настільки важлива задача в обробці сигналів, наприклад, що швидке перетворення Фур'є
вважається багатьма одним із найважливіших і найвпливовіших алгоритмів з будь-коли відкритих.
Ми також можемо думати про дискретне перетворення Фур'є як про унітарну квантову операцію, яку можна застосувати до квантового вектора стану.
І коли ми думаємо про нього таким чином, ми називаємо його квантовим перетворенням Фур'є, або QFT скорочено.
Математично це по суті те саме, що дискретне перетворення Фур'є, але ми називаємо його квантовим перетворенням Фур'є,
просто щоб уточнити, що це операція, яка застосовується до квантового вектора стану.
Тому змінімо назву нашої матриці з V на QFT чотири, щоб відобразити той факт,
що операція, яку ми отримали, — це насправді квантове перетворення Фур'є.
Ось повний circuit для знаходження значення Y, коли нам обіцяно, що theta дорівнює Y поділити на чотири
для Y рівного нулю, одному, двом або трьом.
І для ясності, ми застосовуємо обернене квантове перетворення Фур'є, або іншими словами QFT чотири спряжену,
щоб перетворити один із чотирьох можливих станів назад до стандартного базисного стану кет Y, щоб ми могли відновити Y шляхом вимірювання.
Це circuit, який ми отримуємо, думаючи про обіцяну версію задачі оцінки фази, де нам обіцяно, що theta —
нуль, одна четверта, одна друга або три четверті, але ніщо не заважає нам
запускати цей circuit для довільного значення theta.
І якщо ми так робимо, ось імовірності для чотирьох можливих результатів, які ми отримуємо.
Кожне з чотирьох можливих значень Y має свій колір, і графік показує, якими є імовірності для кожного з них як функції theta.
Наприклад, якщо theta дорівнює трьом четвертим, ми отримаємо результат три з імовірністю одиниця,
тоді як імовірності для інших трьох результатів рівні нулю, як ми вже знаємо, думаючи про обіцяну версію задачі.
Якщо theta близька до трьох четвертих, але не точно три четверті, буде ненульова імовірність для інших результатів,
але ми все одно отримаємо результат три з великою імовірністю.
Тому, навіть якщо theta може не дорівнювати Y поділеному на чотири, ми все одно можемо думати про результат, отриманий від вимірювань, поділений на чотири,
як про здогадку або апроксимацію theta.
Здогадка може бути невірною, але тим не менш вона надає нам інформацію.
І одна річ, яку ми можемо дізнатись із графіку, — що найкращі апроксимації завжди мають найвищі пов'язані з ними імовірності.
Кажучи «найкраща апроксимація», я маю на увазі будь-яке значення Y поділеного на чотири, яке найближче до справжнього значення theta,
за модулем один. Найгірший можливий випадок — коли theta знаходиться рівно посередині між двома значеннями Y поділеного на чотири.
Наприклад, якщо theta дорівнює трьом восьмим або 0.375, у цьому випадку ми бачимо, що апроксимації
одна четверта та дві четверті або одна друга однаково хороші.
Тому в цьому конкретному випадку насправді є дві найкращі апроксимації, а не одна.
І ми однаково ймовірно отримаємо результат один та результат два.
Два інших результати — нуль та три, — які не дають дуже хорошої апроксимації theta при діленні на чотири, насправді з'являються з певною імовірністю,
яка здається лише близько 10% в обох випадках.
Тож ця процедура не є досконалою, але вона надає нам інформацію.
І варто зазначити, що незалежно від theta, нам завжди гарантовано отримати або найкращу апроксимацію,
або одну з двох найкращих апроксимацій при рівності, з імовірністю, яка здається трохи більше 40%.
WEBVTT
І чим ближче theta до апроксимації, тим вища імовірність побачити відповідне значення Y.
І це досить значне покращення порівняно з використанням одного керувального qubit.
Це насправді і є процедура оцінки фази, коли ми вирішуємо використовувати два керувальні qubits.
І далі ми узагальнимо цю процедуру природним чином, де ми не зупиняємось на двох керувальних qubits,
а використовуємо скільки завгодно керувальних qubits.
І ми побачимо, що, узагальнюючи процедуру, додаючи більше керувальних qubits, ми зможемо отримувати дедалі точніші
апроксимації theta. І це буде загальна процедура оцінки фази.
Щоб узагальнити процедуру оцінки фази від двох керувальних qubits до будь-якої їх кількості, нам потрібно зрозуміти,
як квантове перетворення Фур'є визначається для інших вимірів.
А також потрібно обговорити, як його можна реалізувати за допомогою квантового circuit.
Ось визначення квантового перетворення Фур'є, коли вимір є довільним додатним цілим числом N.
Тут ми думаємо про цю операцію як про операцію над системою, класичні стани якої — від нуля до N мінус один.
А матриця, що описує цю операцію, виражена з використанням прямої нотації.
Ми також можемо описати її з точки зору її дії на стандартних базисних станах, просто щоб зв'язати це з тим, що ми вже бачили, коли N дорівнює чотирьом.
Ось як воно виглядає, коли N дорівнює одиниці, що не є дуже цікавим випадком.
Ось при N рівному двом, і ти помітиш, що в цьому випадку ми отримуємо операцію Hadamard.
Ось квантове перетворення Фур'є для N рівного трьом.
Для N рівного чотирьом, що ми вже бачили.
І для останнього прикладу — ось воно при N рівному восьми.
Так само, як і раніше для N рівного чотирьом, — це матриці, які ми пов'язуємо з дискретним перетворенням Фур'є
для кожного з вимірів. Але ми називаємо їх квантовим перетворенням Фур'є, коли хочемо думати про них як про квантові операції.
Іноді, до речі, провідний коефіцієнт один через корінь із N не включається, коли ми думаємо про дискретне перетворення Фур'є як про матрицю,
але він потрібен тут, щоб переконатися, що ми отримуємо унітарну матрицю.
Також іноді у кожному показнику є знак мінус, але не завжди.
Це в основному лише питання особистих уподобань, що не змінює фундаментальної природи перетворення.
Але в будь-якому разі ми визначатимемо квантове перетворення Фур'є так, як воно записано тут на екрані.
Існує дуже корисне скорочення, яке є поширеним і яким ми скористаємось трохи пізніше в уроці.
А саме: визначити комплексне число omega N, як тут.
Конкретно як E у ступені два pi I поділити на N, що також можна записати через синуси і косинуси,
як тут. Іноді ми називаємо це число N-м коренем із одиниці, тому що якщо ми підносимо його до степеня N, ми отримуємо одиницю.
Ось малюнок із кількома прикладами.
Omega один дорівнює одиниці, omega два дорівнює мінус одиниці, а omega чотири дорівнює I.
Загалом, щоб отримати omega N, можна уявити, що ми нарізаємо одиничне коло на N рівних частин, ніби ділимо піцу між N людьми,
і omega N знаходиться на куті першого шматка, за умови, що інший кут цього шматка — на одиниці.
Тому, зокрема, зі збільшенням N шматки ставатимуть дедалі меншими, а omega N наближатиметься дедалі ближче до одиниці.
А тепер, якщо ми використаємо цю нотацію, ми можемо виразити квантове перетворення Фур'є трохи більш компактно.
Іноді ця нотація допомагає зберегти простоту, як ми побачимо трохи пізніше в уроці.
Існує ефективна реалізація на квантовому circuit квантового перетворення Фур'є, коли N є степенем двійки,
на яку ми зараз поглянемо. Хоча ми зазвичай визначаємо квантове перетворення Фур'є для будь-якого виміру N, нам воно знадобиться
лише у випадку, коли N є степенем двійки, щоб узагальнити процедуру оцінки фази.
Реалізація буде використовувати контрольовані фазові gate, зображені так, як показано тут на екрані.
Вони виглядають як два керування, з'єднані разом, разом із числом, яке в даному випадку є alpha.
І дія цього gate описується матрицею, показаною тут.
Це буквально контрольовані фазові gate, тобто у нас є керувальний qubit, який керує фазовим gate.
Ми бачили фазові gate ще в першому уроці.
Але для фазових gate, зокрема, насправді не важливо, який qubit є керувальним, а який — цільовим.
Ми бачили це в уроці два, для конкретного випадку gate Z.
І тепер, маючи це поняття, ми можемо перейти до того, як квантове перетворення Фур'є може бути реалізоване.
WEBVTT
Реалізація є рекурсивною за своєю природою, і, мабуть, найпростіший спосіб описати її в простих термінах — навести приклад, який легко узагальнюється.
Ось як ми можемо це зробити, коли N дорівнює 32.
Отже, є п'ять qubits.
Для ясності, ми пов'язуємо стандартні базисні стани цих п'яти qubits із цілими числами від нуля до 31 за допомогою двійкового запису.
Перше, що ми робимо, — це виконуємо квантове перетворення Фур'є для N рівного 16 для всіх qubits, крім молодшого значущого qubit,
яким є верхній. І це є рекурсивна частина конструкції.
Тому щоб реалізувати цю операцію, ми повинні дотримуватись того самого шаблону, але з одним qubit менше.
А у базовому випадку у нас є лише один qubit, для якого квантове перетворення Фур'є — це просто Hadamard gate.
Після того як ми застосовуємо QFT до всіх qubits, крім верхнього, ми застосовуємо кілька контрольованих фазових gate, використовуючи фази, зазначені на діаграмі.
Потім ми застосовуємо Hadamard gate до верхнього qubit і трохи перемішуємо qubits за допомогою кількох swap gate.
Ці swap gate мають ефект циклічної перестановки qubits, що необхідно для роботи конструкції.
Ми можемо дотримуватись точно такого ж шаблону для інших значень N, за умови, що вони є степенями двійки, де ми завжди починаємо контрольовані фазові gate
з alpha рівним pi поділити на два для нижнього qubit і ділимо на два кожного разу, рухаючись ліворуч на діаграмі,
щоб отримати наступні фази. Тепер те, що ця конструкція працює, зовсім не очевидно.
І я не буду пояснювати, чому вона працює у цьому відео.
Якщо тебе цікавлять деталі того, чому вона працює, ти можеш знайти їх у письмовому матеріалі до уроку.
Скажу, однак, що тут використовується базова структура дискретних перетворень Фур'є,
і насправді це та сама структура, яка дозволяє швидкому перетворенню Фур'є працювати.
Інший спосіб сказати це: якщо ми подивимось на швидке перетворення Фур'є, ми можемо думати про нього в термінах квантових circuits.
І ось circuit, який ми отримуємо.
Скільки gate нам потрібно загалом для цієї реалізації?
Щоб з'ясувати це, нехай SM буде кількістю gate, які нам потрібні, коли ми маємо M qubits.
Коли M дорівнює одиниці, нам потрібен лише один gate, оскільки QFT — це просто операція Hadamard у цьому випадку.
Якщо M не менше двох, то нам потрібні ці gate.
По-перше, нам потрібно SM мінус один gate для квантового перетворення Фур'є на M мінус один qubits, якою б не була ця кількість.
Також нам потрібно M мінус один контрольованих фазових gate, M мінус один swap gate,
та один додатковий Hadamard gate.
Ось вираз для SM в обох випадках — коли M дорівнює одиниці і коли M не менше двох.
Це приклад того, що називається рекурентним співвідношенням, і вони дуже часто зустрічаються в аналізі алгоритмів.
Це конкретне співвідношення виявляється дуже простим і має так звану замкнуту форму, яку ми можемо отримати шляхом підсумовування.
Якщо точно, то значення SM — це сума перших M непарних цілих чисел підряд, що дорівнює M у квадраті,
як ти, можливо, або вже стикався з цим, або помітив колись у житті.
І цю формулу досить легко довести методом індукції по M, якщо тебе цікавить формальний доказ.
Ось і все. Ми можемо реалізувати квантове перетворення Фур'є на M qubits, використовуючи M у квадраті gate.
Лише кілька дуже коротких додаткових зауважень.
По-перше, насправді нам не потрібні всі swap gate, які я описав.
Можливо ефективно перемістити їх усі в кінець, якщо ми відповідно скоригуємо, на які qubits діють контрольовані фазові gate.
І якщо ми це зробимо, нам знадобиться лише M поділити на два swap gate загалом, округлюючи вниз.
Вартість залишиться квадратичною, але кількість gate може бути зменшена таким чином.
І останнє зауваження: ми можемо ще більше зменшити вартість, якщо готові задовольнитись досить хорошою апроксимацією.
Наприклад, зі збільшенням M багато контрольованих фазових gate стають досить близькими до операції тотожності,
і виключення тих, що дуже близькі, може заощадити нам значну кількість gate, при цьому все ще даючи досить хорошу апроксимацію.
Також можна апроксимувати квантове перетворення Фур'є дуже неглибокими circuits, тобто з малою глибиною, якщо це щось, що ми хочемо зробити.
І тепер, коли ми знаємо, що являє собою квантове перетворення Фур'є для різних вимірів, а також те, як його можна реалізувати, коли вимір є степенем двійки,
ми можемо повернутись до процедури оцінки фази і подивитись, як її можна узагальнити, використовуючи деяку довільну кількість M керувальних qubits.
Ось як виглядає ця процедура у вигляді квантового circuit для довільного вибору M.
Зверху у нас є M керувальних qubits, які, як ми припускаємо, всі ініціалізовані нульовим станом.
Ми застосовуємо Hadamard gate до кожного з них, і потім кожен із них використовується як керувальний qubit для застосування деякого степеня унітарної операції U,
WEBVTT
де ми подвоюємо кількість застосувань U для кожного керувального qubit.
Тут на цій діаграмі я позначив це, включивши степені для U всередині квадратів, а не показуючи контрольований gate U,
застосований стільки разів — щоб зробити діаграму зрозумілішою і зекономити місце, щоб усе вмістилось на екрані.
Перше, що нам потрібно зауважити щодо цієї процедури, — що вона може стати дуже витратною.
Зокрема, ми подвоюємо кількість застосувань операції U для кожного керувального qubit.
І якщо ми робимо це, просто ітеруючи контрольований gate U стільки разів, скільки потрібно,
ми отримаємо величезний circuit. Він буде експоненціально великим відносно числа M.
Це є суттєвим обмеженням в загальному випадку, і зокрема це обмежує нашу здатність отримувати точні апроксимації власних значень.
У конкретному випадку факторизації, до якого ми невдовзі дійдемо, нам дуже пощастило: можна використати трюк, який дозволяє нам
уникнути цього експоненціального зростання вартості.
Але загалом, для довільних унітарних операцій U, це буде неможливо, і ми заплатимо велику ціну
за збільшення кількості керувальних qubits.
Я не збираюсь проводити детальний аналіз circuit у цьому відео, а натомість лише зазначу, що є досить простий вираз для стану
безпосередньо перед вимірюваннями, показаний тут на екрані.
З цього стану ми можемо отримати вираз для імовірностей різних результатів, і він виглядає ось так.
І маючи цей вираз, ми можемо міркувати про нього, і насправді цього виразу нам достатньо, щоб продовжити.
Як я вже казав, я не збираюсь вдаватися в деталі у цьому відео, але ти можеш знайти їх у письмовому матеріалі до уроку, і виявляється, що це насправді не так складно,
тож ознайомся, якщо хочеш. Якщо ми проведемо аналіз, то виявимо, що ситуація
не надто відрізняється від випадку M рівного двом, за винятком того, що ми отримуємо більшу точність.
Зокрема, ми можемо спочатку думати про імовірність отримати найкращу або одну з двох найкращих апроксимацій,
що ми можемо виразити так, як тут.
Ти можеш ігнорувати цей нижній індекс один на символі абсолютного значення, якщо хочеш.
Це просто символ, який ми можемо використовувати, щоб нагадати собі, що ми говоримо про апроксимації на колі, де ми вважаємо theta рівне нулю
і theta рівне одиниці тим самим. Суть тут у тому, що ми думаємо про будь-який вибір Y, що робить Y поділити на два у степені M
якомога ближчим до theta.
І знову ж таки, так само, як і для випадку M рівного двом, нам гарантовано отримати цей результат Y з імовірністю принаймні 40%.
Насправді, імовірність не менша за чотири поділити на pi у квадраті, що трохи більше 40%.
10 — непогана апроксимація pi у квадраті, коли ти поспішаєш.
І це насправді досить дивовижно. Ми говоримо про отримання найкращої апроксимації theta у вигляді дробу Y поділити на два у степені M,
де Y — ціле число. І ми отримуємо найкращу апроксимацію з імовірністю більше 40%.
Ми також можемо думати про гірші апроксимації.
Зокрема, уявімо, що Y не є настільки хорошим, і більш конкретно припустимо,
що існує краща апроксимація theta тієї самої форми, яка лежить між theta та Y поділити на два у степені M,
що можна виразити так, як записано на екрані.
У такому випадку імовірність отримати цей Y буде відносно невеликою — не більше 25%.
Насправді вона буде нижчою, але 25% — це те, що ми отримуємо з досить простого аналізу, і цього достатньо.
Як приклад. Ось графік, який ми отримуємо при використанні трьох керувальних qubits замість двох.
Цього разу я будую графік лише для результатів три, чотири та п'ять, тому що не хочу, щоб малюнок був занадто перевантаженим.
Коли theta дорівнює одній другій, наприклад, нам гарантовано отримати результат чотири.
І тому ми беремо нашу апроксимацію як чотири восьмих або одна друга, тому що два у степені три — це вісім.
І в цьому випадку ми абсолютно праві. І поки theta ближча до одній другій, ніж, скажімо, до трьох восьмих,
ми отримуємо результат чотири з імовірністю вищою, ніж результат три.
І з імовірністю, знову ж таки, більшою за 40%.
Ось графік при M рівному чотирьом. І криві насправді виглядають майже однаково, за винятком того, що тепер ми збільшили масштаб удвічі.
Тож тепер результати на графіку включають сім, вісім та дев'ять, і ми беремо апроксимацію як одне з цих чисел, поділене на 16, а не на вісім.
І покажу ще один графік, де ми збільшуємо до M рівного п'яти.
І знову ми збільшимо масштаб удвічі.
Ось воно. Знову ж таки, криві виглядають майже однаково, але ми фактично подвоюємо точність.
WEBVTT
І як і раніше, ми отримуємо найкращу апроксимацію theta з імовірністю більше 40%.
Це досить дивовижно. Але якщо 40% недостатньо як міра впевненості,
ми можемо запустити процедуру кілька разів і взяти моду результатів, тобто той, що з'являється найчастіше.
І якщо ми так робимо, ми з великою імовірністю отримаємо дуже хорошу апроксимацію theta.
До речі, пам'ятай, що кожного разу, коли ми запускаємо процедуру оцінки фази, власний вектор виходить незмінним.
Тому він доступний для того, щоб ми запускали процедуру кілька разів ось так.
Коротко кажучи, ми збираємо статистику про theta, і суть у тому, що, роблячи це, ми можемо отримати дуже точну апроксимацію theta
з дуже високим рівнем впевненості, і для цього нам не потрібно багато ітерацій процедури.
Ось як працює процедура оцінки фази.
В останній частині уроку ми застосуємо техніку оцінки фази до задачі факторизації цілих чисел.
Як я згадував на початку відео, це працює так: ми розглядаємо проміжну задачу, відому як задача пошуку порядку.
Ми побачимо, як можна розв'язати задачу пошуку порядку за допомогою оцінки фази, а потім коротко обговоримо, як розв'язання задачі пошуку порядку
дозволяє нам ефективно факторизувати цілі числа.
Друга частина є повністю класичною, і я лише узагальню основну ідею в цьому відео.
Але давайте почнемо із задачі пошуку порядку.
Спочатку введемо зручні позначення.
Для кожного додатного цілого числа N ми визначаємо ZN як цілі числа від нуля до N мінус один.
Так, наприклад, Z один має один елемент — нуль, Z два має елементи нуль та один,
Z три має елементи нуль, один та два, і так далі.
Тобто ZN — це множина.
Але ми також можемо думати про неї як про щось більше, ніж множину. Ми можемо думати про арифметичні операції, такі як додавання та множення над ZN,
визначаючи їх за модулем N.
Наприклад, припустимо, що N дорівнює семи.
Три та п'ять є елементами Z сім, і якщо ми їх перемножимо, ми отримаємо 15,
що дає залишок один після ділення на сім.
Іноді ми виражаємо це, записуючи, що три помножене на п'ять є конгруентним до одиниці за модулем сім, як тут записано.
Але ми також можемо просто написати, що три помножене на п'ять дорівнює одному.
Звичайно, три помножене на п'ять зазвичай не дорівнює одному, воно дорівнює 15.
Але коли зрозуміло, що ми працюємо в Z сім, тобто що множення визначено за модулем сім,
ми можемо просто написати, що три помножене на п'ять дорівнює одному.
Тепер серед елементів ZN для будь-якого додатного N деякі матимуть НСД рівний одиниці з N,
а деякі — ні. І ті елементи, що мають НСД рівний одиниці з N, є особливими.
Ми записуємо ZN зірочка, щоб позначити множину лише цих елементів.
Наприклад, ось Z 21 зірочка.
Серед елементів Z 21, яких є 21, виявляється, що 12 із них мають НСД рівний одиниці з 21, а решта — ні.
Зокрема, щоразу, коли у нас є елемент Z 21, що ділиться або на три, або на сім, ми його пропускаємо.
Є різні причини, чому ця множина є особливою, і одна з причин полягає в тому, що щоразу, коли ми маємо елемент ZN зірочка
і розглядаємо додатні цілі степені цього числа, ми завжди врешті-решт потрапимо до числа один,
де, як і раніше, ми говоримо про множення за модулем N.
Найменший додатний цілий степінь, що дає нам одиницю, називається порядком цього елемента.
Наприклад, розглянемо елемент A рівний чотирьом у Z 21 зірочка.
Чотири помножене на чотири — це 16, що не дорівнює одиниці за модулем 21, але якщо ми ще раз помножимо на чотири,
ми отримаємо 64, а 64 за модулем 21 дорівнює одиниці.
Тому порядок чотири за модулем 21 дорівнює трьом.
Досягнення одиниці таким чином завжди відбувається для всіх елементів ZN зірочка.
До речі, цього ніколи не відбувається для елементів ZN, які не входять до ZN зірочка.
Тому наявність НСД рівного одиниці з N є необхідною і достатньою умовою для цього.
І щоб завершити приклад N рівного 21, ось найменші додатні цілі степені, для яких це виконується, для кожного елемента Z 21 зірочка,
і їх можна перевірити по одному.
А тепер ми можемо сформулювати задачу пошуку порядку, що полягає просто у знаходженні порядку для заданого елемента ZN зірочка.
WEBVTT
Якщо точно, то вхідні дані — це два додатних цілих числа A та N, для яких НСД дорівнює одиниці,
а результат — найменше додатне ціле число R таке, що A у степені R є конгруентним до одиниці за модулем N,
або еквівалентно, найменше додатне ціле число R, для якого A у степені R дорівнює одиниці.
Якщо ми виконуємо арифметику в ZN.
Вважається, що це є обчислювально важкою задачею: ефективного класичного алгоритму для її розв'язання не відомо.
І, як ми обговоримо, задача є принаймні такою ж складною, як факторизація цілих чисел у тому сенсі, що якщо ми маємо алгоритм для розв'язання пошуку порядку,
ми зможемо використовувати цей алгоритм для ефективного розв'язання задачі факторизації цілих чисел.
Насправді, вірне й зворотне, тобто якщо у тебе є алгоритм для факторизації, ти можеш використовувати його для розв'язання задачі пошуку порядку.
Тому ці дві задачі певною мірою еквівалентні з точки зору обчислювальної складності.
Тепер ми побачимо, як можна розв'язати задачу пошуку порядку на квантовому комп'ютері за допомогою оцінки фази.
Щоб встановити зв'язок між задачами, уявімо, що у нас є система, класичною множиною станів якої є AN.
Для будь-якого вибору елемента A у ZN зірочка ми визначимо операцію MA, як тут.
Словами: MA множить на A, і тут множення відбувається за модулем N.
І на решту уроку ти повинен завжди думати про вирази всередині кетів як про обчислені за модулем N,
просто щоб зберегти простоту і не писати mod N знову і знову.
Це унітарна операція, але це правда лише тоді, коли A є елементом ZN зірочка.
Якщо НСД від A та N не дорівнює одиниці, ця операція не буде унітарною.
Ось приклад. Якщо N дорівнює 15 і A дорівнює двом, що є елементом Z 15 зірочка, то ось дія M два.
І якщо ти розглянеш цей приклад кілька хвилин, то побачиш, що відбувається: елементи ZN просто переставляються цією дією.
Тому вона є детермінованою та унітарною, тобто як матриця MA є матрицею перестановок.
Ось головна ідея. Власні значення MA дуже тісно пов'язані
з порядком A. І використовуючи оцінку фази для апроксимації цих власних значень достатньо точно,
ми можемо визначити порядок A. Тож якими саме є власні вектори та власні значення MA?
Ну, нам не потрібні всі з них, нам потрібні лише деякі.
Почнемо з простого прикладу.
Ось власний вектор MA, ми назвали його psi нуль, і він задається сумою кет один, кет a,
кет A у квадраті, і так далі аж до кет A у степені R мінус один, усі поділені на корінь із R,
щоб зробити його одиничним вектором. Тут R — порядок A.
І я залишу літеру R для позначення порядку A на решту уроку.
Тому щоразу, коли ти бачиш R, це порядок A для того A, про який йдеться.
Власне значення, пов'язане з цим власним вектором, дорівнює одиниці.
І ми можемо перевірити це, застосовуючи MA до цього вектора, щоб побачити, що ми отримаємо.
MA множить на A, тому нам просто потрібно збільшити кожен із показників на один, і ось що ми отримуємо.
Але порядок A дорівнює R, тому A у степені R дорівнює одиниці.
І ми можемо зробити цю заміну.
Але це той самий вектор, з якого ми починали. Ми лише переставили кети, але беремо суму, тому це нічого не змінює.
Тому MA помножене на psi нуль дорівнює psi нуль.
Тобто це власний вектор MA з власним значенням одиниця.
Це дуже простий приклад власного вектора, і щоб знайти більше, давай згадаємо ту саму нотацію, що була раніше в уроці.
Omega R — це комплексне число на одиничному колі, яке ми отримуємо, беручи E у степені два помножене на pi помножене на I,
поділене на R. Минулого разу у нас було N замість R, але це працює так само з R замість N.
Це число нам потрібне, бо воно з'явиться в інших власних векторах MA, які ми визначимо.
І тепер, згадавши цю нотацію, ми можемо спостерігати, що цей вектор, названий psi один, також є власним вектором MA.
Він схожий на psi нуль: у нас є точно ті самі кети, і ми їх підсумовуємо та ділимо на корінь із R.
Але цього разу є різні фази, що множать кожен із кетів.
Omega R у степені мінус один для A, omega R у степені мінус два для A у квадраті, і так далі аж до omega R у степені мінус R мінус один
для A у степені R мінус один. Тобто показник omega R завжди дорівнює мінус одиниці, помноженій на той показник, у якому A знаходиться всередині кету.
Я не буду розбирати це детально, але воно показано на екрані, якщо ти хочеш переглянути відео ще раз і зупинитись у потрібний момент.
Але якщо ми виконаємо множення та спростимо знову, використовуючи той факт, що A у степені R дорівнює одиниці,
а також дуже важливий факт, що omega у степені R дорівнює одиниці, ми виявимо, що у нас знову є власний вектор MA.
WEBVTT
Цього разу, виконуючи спрощення, нам потрібно буде винести множник omega R, щоб побачити, що це справді власний вектор,
і цей вектор omega R представляє власне значення, пов'язане з цим власним вектором.
Це друга пара власний вектор — власне значення для NA.
Ми можемо знайти додаткові власні вектори, використовуючи точно таке ж міркування, і насправді, якщо ми просто замінимо omega R
на omega R у степені J для кожного J від нуля до R мінус один, ми завжди отримаємо власний вектор,
і відповідне власне значення буде omega R у степені J.
Тому це насправді включає psi нуль та psi один, які ми вже бачили, а також R мінус два інших пари власний вектор — власне значення.
Вони всі працюють в основному однаково, і щоб перевірити їх, нам просто потрібно знати, що A у степені R дорівнює одиниці,
а також що omega R у степені R дорівнює одиниці.
Є й інші власні вектори MA, такі як кет нуль, наприклад, але вони не будуть корисні для нас, і нам не потрібно про них турбуватись.
Нам потрібно думати лише про psi нуль через psi R мінус один.
Зосередимось на psi один на мить, просто щоб спробувати зрозуміти, чому ці власні вектори нас цікавлять
і що вони можуть розповісти нам про порядок R, який ми намагаємось знайти.
Припустимо, що нам дано власний вектор psi один, ми можемо спробувати дізнатись R таким чином.
По-перше, ми виконуємо оцінку фази для цього власного вектора, використовуючи квантовий circuit, який реалізує операцію MA.
Ми отримаємо апроксимацію до theta, яка в цьому випадку дорівнює одному поділеному на R.
І по-друге, оскільки ми шукаємо R і маємо апроксимацію до одного поділеного на R, природна річ — обчислити обернений елемент
і заокруглити до найближчого цілого числа. Нам потрібно заокруглити, тому що R має бути цілим числом.
Але у нас немає точного значення одного поділеного на R, у нас лише його апроксимація.
Але якщо апроксимація достатньо хороша, ми отримаємо R після заокруглення, що і є тим, що ми шукаємо.
І тепер питання: скільки точності нам потрібно, щоб правильно визначити R, обчислюючи обернений елемент і заокруглюючи?
Або іншими словами, наскільки точною повинна бути наша апроксимація, щоб усе це спрацювало?
Виявляється, нам потрібна досить точна апроксимація.
Наприклад, ми не можемо дозволити собі переплутати одне поділене на R з одним поділеним на R плюс один, або одним поділеним на R мінус один.
У цих двох дробах одне поділене на R плюс один та одне поділене на R мінус один досить близькі до одного поділеного на R, коли R є великим.
Але хоча нам і потрібна досить точна апроксимація, нам не потрібна надзвичайно точна апроксимація, і можна показати, що якщо наша апроксимація
задовольняє нерівність, показану тут на екрані, то заокруглення дасть нам правильну відповідь.
Я не буду намагатись довести це у цьому відео, але це показано в письмовому матеріалі до уроку, якщо тебе цікавлять деталі.
І якщо це та точність, до якої ми прагнемо, то достатньо використовувати кількість керувальних qubits у процедурі оцінки фази,
рівну двом, помноженим на довжину N плюс один.
Де, як ми мали в попередніх уроках, довжина N — це кількість бітів, необхідна для вираження N у двійковому записі.
До речі, якщо нас влаштовує отримати найкращу апроксимацію з імовірністю принаймні 40% і ми не намагаємось збільшити нашу впевненість,
як я описував раніше, то нам насправді не потрібен плюс один.
Але в будь-якому разі у нас є, що кількість керувальних qubits, які нам потрібні, лінійна від довжини N, записаного як двійковий рядок.
Ми бачили, що якщо у нас є власний вектор psi один, ми можемо використовувати оцінку фази для знаходження R, за умови, що ми використовуємо достатньо точності.
На жаль, отримати цей власний вектор не так просто.
Тому поставимо інше питання.
Припустимо, у нас немає psi один, а натомість є psi для випадкового вибору J.
Чи можемо ми все одно з'ясувати, чому дорівнює R? Або принаймні чи можемо ми дізнатись щось про R?
І відповідь — так, ми можемо дізнатись щось про R, принаймні в середньому.
Ми можемо спробувати з'ясувати J поділене на R, використовуючи дуже схожий метод до того, що ми щойно бачили,
але з ключовою відмінністю.
По-перше, ми зробимо точно те саме, що робили раніше, — запустимо процедуру оцінки фази для власного вектора psi J.
І ми отримаємо апроксимацію до J поділеного на R, на відміну від одного поділеного на R, як раніше.
Але тепер у нас невелика проблема, оскільки обчислення оберненого не дасть нам R, а дасть R поділене на J.
До речі, ми не припускаємо, що знаємо, чому дорівнює J, — нам просто дано psi J для випадкового J,
і нам не кажуть, чому дорівнює J. Тож що ми можемо зробити?
Виявляється, є добре відомий класичний алгоритм, який може нам допомогти, — він називається алгоритм неперервних дробів.
І цей алгоритм може взяти нашу апроксимацію Y поділене на два у степені M і повідомити нам, який дріб U поділити на V,
записаний у найменших термінах, де U та V є цілими числами, меншими за N, є найближчим до нашої апроксимації.
WEBVTT
Це справді захоплюючий алгоритм, і якщо тебе він цікавить, обов'язково ознайомся з ним.
Він дуже тісно пов'язаний з алгоритмом Евкліда для обчислення НСД.
Але я не скажу про нього більше нічого у цьому відео.
Суть у тому, що якщо у нас є хороша апроксимація деякого дробу, де чисельник та знаменник не надто великі,
алгоритм може відновити цей дріб, і саме це ми тут і робимо.
І тепер ми стоїмо перед точно тим самим питанням, що й раніше, — скільки точності нам потрібно?
Виявляється, та сама оцінка, що й раніше, підходить і в цьому випадку.
І тому вибір M точно так само, як і раніше, підходить і тут.
Тепер це не обов'язково скаже нам R.
Якщо ми використовуємо достатньо точності, ми дізнаємось J поділене на R, але це буде дріб у найменших термінах.
Тому нам може не пощастити в тому сенсі, що цей випадковий вибір J може мати спільні множники з R,
і вони будуть від нас приховані. У найгіршому випадку, наприклад, ми могли б отримати J рівне нулю і не дізнаємось абсолютно нічого.
Але це буквально єдиний випадок, коли ми нічого не дізнаємось.
Загалом ми отримаємо принаймні нетривіальний дільник R, і якщо ми зможемо отримувати випадкові вибірки
і отримувати psi J для різних значень J, ми можемо насправді відновити R з великою імовірністю, обчислюючи найменше спільне кратне
всіх знаменників, які ми спостерігаємо. І для цього насправді не потрібно багато вибірок.
Суть у тому, що деякі значення J приховуватимуть множники R, але випадкові значення J
не зможуть надовго приховати множники R.
Ось і вся ідея. Залишається розглянути реалізацію і зокрема з'ясувати, скільки вона коштує.
Суть ідеї для обчислення порядку заданого елемента A у ZN зірочка полягає у застосуванні процедури оцінки фази
до операції MA.
З'ясуємо, якою є вартість цього як функція від довжини великого N, яку я позначу маленьким n.
Ось circuit для оцінки фази. Нам знадобиться маленьке n qubits у нижній частині circuit,
щоб закодувати елементи ZN у двійковому записі. Тому у нас є N керувальних qubits зверху та маленьке n qubits знизу,
що добре, оскільки це відповідає назвам, які ми використовували раніше в уроці.
Щоб підрахувати кількість gate, необхідних для всього circuit, зосередимось спочатку на вартості контрольованих унітарних операцій.
Якщо ми використаємо техніки з попереднього уроку, уроку шість, ми можемо реалізувати MA, використовуючи O від маленького n у квадраті gate,
використовуючи ефективні класичні алгоритми для арифметики за модулем N.
Я пропущу деталі в цьому відео, але, як і кілька інших речей, про які я говорив, ти можеш докладніше прочитати в письмовому матеріалі до уроку.
Але реалізація лише MA недостатня.
Нам також потрібно реалізувати MA у квадраті, MA у четвертому степені, у восьмому степені, і так далі,
аж до MA у ступені, що є експоненціальним від M.
І ми знаємо, що M має бути лінійним від маленького n для достатньої точності.
Це є великою проблемою, і я згадував про це раніше.
Якби ми реалізовували степені MA, просто ітеруючи MA, у нас були б проблеми, тому що всі ці ітерації MA мали б експоненціальну вартість.
На щастя, ми можемо використати трюк, щоб уникнути цього зростання вартості.
Ось що ми можемо зробити для кожного степеня K, який нам потрібен.
По-перше, ми обчислюємо A у степені K за модулем N.
Це задача модульного піднесення до степеня, про яку я згадував в уроці шість.
І її можна розв'язати ефективно. І це те, що ми можемо зробити за допомогою класичного комп'ютера.
Це обчислення не потребує виконання квантовим circuit взагалі.
Тому нехай B буде результатом.
Тобто B є елементом ZN зірочка.
І по-друге, замість MA у степені K ми просто використовуємо circuit для MB.
Ось і все. B — лише деякий елемент ZN зірочка, тому вартість реалізації MB дорівнює O від маленького n у квадраті.
Коротко кажучи, ми піднімаємо до степеня в ZN, а не піднімаємо до степеня квантовий circuit.
Але фактична операція, яку ми отримуємо, однакова в обох випадках. Це просто множення на A K разів.
Це свого роду диво. І ми не змогли б розв'язати задачу пошуку порядку або ефективно факторизувати цілі числа за допомогою квантового комп'ютера,
якби не це.
І тепер, знаючи, що кожна із контрольованих унітарних операцій, включаючи степені, може бути реалізована
з вартістю O від n у квадраті, ми можемо підрахувати загальну кількість gate.
У нас є N Hadamard gate, і оскільки M дорівнює O від маленького n, вартість дорівнює O від маленького n.
WEBVTT
У нас є M контрольованих унітарних операцій, кожна з вартістю O від N у квадраті.
Тому загальна вартість тут дорівнює O від N у кубі.
І нарешті, квантове перетворення Фур'є має вартість O від n у квадраті.
Тому загальна вартість дорівнює O від N у кубі.
Зокрема, ми бачимо, що навіть з нашим трюком модульного піднесення до степеня, вартість контрольованих унітарних операцій переважає.
Але тим не менш, вартість поліноміальна від маленького n.
Є також деякі класичні обчислення, необхідні, як-от обчислення модульних піднесень до степеня та запуск алгоритму неперервних дробів,
але ці обчислення також мають поліноміальну вартість. І насправді вони можуть бути виконані за O від N у кубі операцій.
Є лише одна залишена проблема: нам потрібно отримати один із цих власних векторів.
Як ми можемо це зробити?
Розв'язок насправді дуже простий. Ми не запускаємо circuit на власному векторі.
Ми просто запускаємо його на стані один, тобто двійковому кодуванні числа один, про яке ми думаємо як про елемент ZN.
Тому зробимо цю заміну на діаграмі.
Причина, чому це спрацьовує, — ось це рівняння тут.
Стан кет один насправді є рівномірною суперпозицією R власних векторів, про які ми говорили.
І це не є очевидним, але якщо ти обчислиш суму, ти повинен отримати кет один.
І якщо ми запустимо circuit на цьому стані, результат буде точно таким самим, як якби ми випадково обрали J
і запустили процедуру на власному векторі psi J.
Знову ж таки, це не очевидно, але аналіз показує, що це правда.
І нарешті, ось і все. У нас є ефективний квантовий алгоритм для пошуку порядку.
Є ще одна дуже коротка частина уроку, що стосується зв'язку між факторизацією цілих чисел та пошуком порядку.
Я згадував, що якщо ми можемо ефективно розв'язати задачу пошуку порядку, то ми також можемо ефективно факторизувати цілі числа.
І я хочу дуже коротко пояснити тобі основну ідею того, як це працює.
Це повністю класична частина. Вона насправді не має нічого спільного з квантовими обчисленнями.
Ось метод знаходження нетривіального дільника даного додатного цілого числа N.
До речі, цей метод працює лише тоді, коли N є непарним числом і не є простим числом, зведеним до степеня.
Ці два випадки, коли N парне або є степенем простого числа, можна обробити окремо.
Існують ефективні класичні методи для виявлення та обробки обох цих випадків.
Цей метод є імовірнісним. Він може дати збій, але імовірність збою не перевищуватиме половину,
і ми можемо просто запустити його кілька разів незалежно, щоб зменшити імовірність помилки експоненціально швидко.
По-перше, ми вибираємо A між двійкою та N мінус один випадково, рівномірно.
Потім ми обчислюємо НСД від A та N.
І якщо НСД виявляється більшим за одиницю, нам фантастично пощастило.
НСД буде дільником N, і ми можемо просто видати його та зупинитись.
Інакше алгоритм продовжується, і тепер ми знаємо, що A є елементом ZN зірочка.
І тепер ми обчислюємо порядок A, що і є місцем, де нам потрібен квантовий комп'ютер.
Або, можливо, у нас є інший спосіб обчислення порядку. Алгоритму насправді все одно, звідки він береться, але єдиний спосіб, який ми знаємо, щоб зробити це ефективно, —
це за допомогою квантового комп'ютера.
Якщо порядок R є парним, ми обчислюємо НСД від A у степені R поділити на два мінус один та N.
І якщо цей НСД більший за одиницю, то знову ж таки у нас є дільник N, тому ми видаємо його та зупиняємось.
Інакше алгоритм дав збій. У цьому випадку ми можемо повернутись на початок і вибрати інше A
і сподіватись на кращий результат наступного разу.
Ось і все. До речі, знайшовши дільник N, ми можемо рекурсивно повторити для цього дільника
і поділити на нього, поки не отримаємо просту факторизацію N.
Чому ж це повинно спрацювати?
Є два головних моменти. Перший полягає в тому, що оскільки A у степені R є конгруентним до одиниці за модулем N,
ми маємо, що N ділить A у степені R мінус одиниця.
Ці два твердження насправді еквівалентні. Це визначення mod N, яке ти знайдеш у підручниках з теорії чисел.
По-друге, якщо R є парним, то це рівняння, яке ми маємо тут, є правильним.
Це добре відома формула різниці квадратів.
Насправді, рівняння є правильним для всіх R, але нам потрібно, щоб R поділити на два було цілим числом на кроці чотири.
WEBVTT
І тому, якщо ми поєднаємо ці два факти, ми побачимо, що кожен простий дільник N повинен ділити один із двох виразів у дужках,
бо це єдиний спосіб, яким N може ділити добуток.
Може бути так, що кожен простий дільник N ділить перший вираз у дужках, але не другий, але для нашого випадкового A
це малоймовірно. Тому, обчислюючи НСД на кроці чотири, ми, швидше за все, отримаємо добуток
деяких простих дільників N, але не всіх.
Щоб аналізувати це ретельно, потрібна деяка теорія чисел, але це досить базова теорія чисел.
Тому якщо тебе цікавить теорія чисел і ти хочеш дізнатися про неї більше, спробуй пропрацювати цей аналіз.
Пропрацьовування таких речей — чудовий спосіб дізнатись більше, але я залишу це тобі.
І це кінець уроку. У цьому уроці ми розглянули задачу оцінки фази, те, як її можна ефективно розв'язати на квантовому комп'ютері,
і як ми можемо застосувати розв'язок, щоб отримати квантовий алгоритм із поліноміальною вартістю для факторизації цілих чисел.
Сподіваюсь, ти приєднаєшся до мене на наступному уроці, який присвячений квантовому алгоритму пошуку Гровера.
До зустрічі.